as covet cases do rise there is renewed
concern about getting infected with the
virus even if you are
fully vaccinated and many of those
people are wondering if having a cough
or a fever means they've contracted
covid
oracle mana joining us now live with
what local doctors are saying about this
orko
well denise and brian experts say it's
important to remember that the pandemic
is not over yet while our state has
reopened and mass mandates are gone
we still need to be vigilant that
includes instances when fully vaccinated
people
start to feel sick covet cases in clark
county are rising the delta variant is
more easily transmissible
and local vaccination rates are
plateauing i think
it is something to be you know a little
bit concerned about
while those who are fully vaccinated are
less at risk of getting hospitalized
there's still a small chance of
contracting covid
we know that the vaccine is not a silver
bullet but
it is extraordinarily effective even in
the face of these variants
it is your best defense against this
virus
so what if you're fully immunized and
suddenly feel sick how do you know if
it's a rare covid case or just a cold
unfortunately it's really not possible
to distinguish whether or not you have
covid the delta variant or sometimes
even the common cold
the only way to know for sure if you've
coveted is to get tested for coded
experts add with all the measures we've
taken to prevent covid and now that
masks are not required we are going to
see an
increase in some of these other
transmissible viruses even in those
cases you're recommended to be cautious
if you're sick with anything you
shouldn't be going out in situations
where you can spread disease tether
whether it's coconut or flu or anything
else
you shouldn't be spreading that disease
to other people and when it comes to
covid if you're with crowds of people
and unsure of their vaccination status
it really probably is in your best
interest to wear a mask even if the cdc
doesn't mandate it
now because our vaccination rates are
not at the herd immunity threshold yet
state and local leaders are trying to
ramp up their efforts
the governor announced today that the
state will be launching more mobile
vaccination units at targeted locations
and will also be adding new providers to
make sure that they can administer the
vaccines
directly to patients reporting live in
las vegas tonight orca mana 8 news now